thank you we talked to Miss Davis a
little bit about some reports that we've
received as late as this morning
and so she understands and she said
she'd be willing to meet with you and
talk to you okay but we want to give you
all some privacy too so is this a
suitable yeah we'll just step out here
I'm good how are you
double stand of the week
so what's going on today
they said they had reports where I was
drinking at school
which is never happened
uh last night about what time these quit
drinking uh probably about 10 30 10 30.
how much did you drink
just a glass of wine nothing major okay
all right well would you be willing to
submit to some tests yeah to make sure
everything's okay
okay all right what I'm going to do
first is I'm going to check you for HDM
okay this is what we call standardized
field sobriety test okay
uh there's three of them I'm gonna
pretty much focus on the first one which
is horizontal gaze and the stagness so
I'm gonna have you take your glasses off
I'm going to have you a little stabbed
up when we do this I Am So Blind without
them I can't hardly can you see
something like my finger about six
inches from your face okay yes
absolutely all right let's try that go
ahead and stand up for me
kill the hill Toe to Toe arms straight
down from your side okay
you say you wear glasses yes you need
traumatic brain injuries
okay all right can you see that right
there okay
I want you to follow this
with your eyes and your eyes only don't
move your head you understand okay just
track on that
you try to keep your head as straight as
you can okay
sorry I'm nervous so I did it
get your answering just put your eyes
over here
going to go way up this time I'm getting
just follow right here
okay
all right this is what we call our
portable breathalyzer machine okay
don't you don't have to take the test
okay but this will show the presence of
alcohol if there's anything okay
um
but this again would be your opportunity
if teachers here administrators feel
that they smell alcohol on you this
would be opportunity to improve it sure
okay you're willing to take that test
yes okay
even what I haven't had anything today
and if that's the case or if there's
nothing on board
well if people are tied a really good
one on the night before it can carry
over into the next day so what am I
doing
as far as what you said it can carry
into today it can't
I mean if people get on like a week-long
bender or if they really tie a good one
on the night before you know
alcohol could still be on board
but I can't give you any legal advice to
take it or not to take it I can do is
offer it to you and it's your right to
refuse
but again I'll say this is if you're
saying you're not under the influence
alcohol this is your opportunity to
prove your employer no
like I admitted to you last night yes if
you had one glass of wine last night and
you didn't have anything else after that
one glass of wine isn't going to carry
over into the next one man I went to
sleep okay all right so you want to take
this sure good
oh
I haven't used one I would just like to
know who is said like well man that I
don't know I was just called I know I
just
foreign
tells me it's time to blow I'm gonna
have you reach over with your mouth and
blow into that as hard as you can until
I tell you to stop big deep breath both
hard keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
I don't even know what that 0.06 is that
thank you
you are just under the legal limit
so if you were to be out driving right
now you would be charged with DWI
driving while intoxicated
under the legal limit just under it the
legal limit is .08
which is the UI the from a 0.06 to 107
he could be charging pwi
I haven't had anything to drink today
okay well I'm gonna let Mr
let me ask you this is there anybody
that can come and pick you up here at
the school
yes okay I mean I don't
know
I'm under the
hey major
I can have somebody come pick me up okay
see um let him talk to but I'm under the
legal limit right so so under the legal
limit it just means that you're under
the legal limit it shows that there's
alcohol in your system
so you are still technically intoxicated
you're just under the legal limit of
0.08
like if you were to be out driving right
now and you got pulled over
and you did sfsts like you just did and
did a breathalyzer you could still be
charged for DWI not DUI but ewi okay
does that make sense
kinda okay
if I have somebody that can come pick me
up
that is going to be
um
we need to see what Mr Kenzie wants to
do
and then um
major
seven
you can space those out
it just makes me mad for somebody to say
that I had stuff here
I've never yeah and like ever and I know
it's a small town yeah like major
mountain was saying that we have we're
not we're not privy to that information
we just get a call and come do it you
know what I mean I would
show offer
say that one more time
I get it yeah but just for somebody to
be like so vicious to say like
I just don't get it
that's the right thing to do but it's
also the the thing that will draw
scrutiny and criticism from everybody
yep because she's allowed to go home
with someone else and not be arrested
yeah I think the the thing we'll have to
do there just to speak the school
language here for a second with you is
just she's not going to come back right
she's going to give me a letter if we're
going to do it that way so I'm willing
to to go that way or if she's not
willing to give me a letter resignation
and that's something you'll work out
between with her but from a legal
standpoint I'm going to go ahead and
make the arrest
yeah
all right so you're gonna
write again there's two ways now you can
look at View and arrest as she goes to
jail or I can cite and release on her
own recognizance provider she's got
somebody that's over to come come and
take possession of her and so you're
going to give her
well no that's the decision I'm going to
make before I walk back in that room
okay
and for us it's you know it's nothing
you know our job is not to judge it's
just our job is to do our job you know
trust me that was CPS yeah I
I'm faced on my clients I'm not here to
judge you the way your house looks or
anything but that's the reason I'm here
I took some
people to court yesterday that I had
arrested and he said man I appreciate
you still treat me like a human being
yeah and no one that means a lot yeah
[Music]
okay
Jennifer Davis Jennifer do you have your
idea with you
and it's in your purse
okay we're I'll go again
it's in my room in my cabinet
where's my purse
whatever I need okay it's all in her
purse uh my keys are beside my purse
okay
Jennifer what's your phone number
foreign
okay Jennifer I'm gonna be honest with
you uh this is a portable breathalyzer
machine it reads a little lower than
what the actual intoxicizer which we
utilize at the police department
it reads lower this came up a point zero
zero point zero six six I have not had
any that's what I'm saying I haven't had
anything today
okay well again I don't know your
drinking habits
okay I kind of explained that to you
before I put you on the machine okay if
somebody drinks a lot and if they run
with a normal BAC of say about a 0.06 or
zero eight that's what feels normal to
them okay
when they get start to get below that
that's when neon said it withdrawals
kick in and start getting the shakes and
not feeling so good and then you drink a
little more to get day one normal again
sure that BAC will still be up here okay
from a legal standpoint you're still
you're still intoxicated
uh I'm comfortable enough to let you
know if you were to be put on the actual
hog slider that you'd be up around 0.12
0.13 area okay
but I checked when I checked your eyes
for horizontal gaze and the stacking
that you had every clue
you had the onset and you had the lack
of equal Pursuit you had the onset in
the stack was prior to 45 degrees and
you had nystagnose at Max deviation
okay
if I had pulled you over
I'm gonna be honest with you you get a
better resident for driving under the
influence
that's what he was explaining yeah
can I have somebody pick me up well
I've got to leave I've got a legal
obligation okay
you're here
entrusted
for the care and safety and the teachers
okay
no today you're going to be arrested for
public intoxication
okay
I will have my sister come get me I
don't write the law and I will resign
that's something you're going to discuss
with the administration here but I've
made my decision
okay
it's zero tolerance
I would just like to know who report
like and I did not drink today well I'm
going to tell you from a legal
standpoint when people call in and
report a crime of any crime we're not in
the business of telling people who made
the report I have reasons behind that I
understand that okay
so you're taking me to County
and it's going to be a municipal charge
I'm not going to run it through the
district court it'll be through the city
to come soon this will charge a public
intoxication
okay
in terms of your employment here
Jennifer we
can't move forward with you being a
teacher here any longer okay if you want
to resign
that's your option
if you choose not to though I would be
forced to go to the board and ask for
your termination based on the outcome of
today so
foreign
oh I know
the police department operates under
policies and procedures and I can't
treat you any more different than
anybody else or we're setting ourselves
up for liability now I'm not going to
run you down the hallways and trade you
through my child is in the third grade
hole where where's the classroom window
at
all right it doesn't face up to this
parking lot right here I don't know okay
would your ID be in here yeah I can get
it I'll get it for you once you're in
custody we have to search all belongings
okay
is there anything in here I need to know
about just my medication that I take
daily
Jennifer with your with Maisie being
here
is there someone you can contact
my sister can I can I call her now
can I call my sister I'll let you do
that please
please
yeah
you take any prescription narcotics
Xanax
go ahead
[Music]
um
is that for anxiety yes
clear
my
so messy but on the side is where my
license is
clear
uh-huh
Seven Central One by OLN
you will be picking Macy up today
okay well they're taking me to sam082
one two one six seven zero
somebody called in and said
no
yeah
last night but nothing
am I going am I going to count like
where am I to the safety center it's on
what's up
now explain to her ma'am
once you're booked in like I said it's a
municipal charge of Pi it is a bondable
charge so sending your book in somebody
seven to three
drinking this morning that's what I'm
nobody
okay
is there anybody that can come out there
and get me
anybody
okay seven to three
do you think um but you will be able to
pick up Maisie
okay
yes sir I was
burglar alarm
I was gonna see if he could take that
call
Jennifer we want if we want to go and
take care of the letter here there's one
that's been drafted for you if you'd
prefer to write one
get you to sign in just put today's date
on it if you're angry
seventh
okay
again our policy and procedure stay
anybody that goes into that yeah
a little bit okay when you remain calm
we're gonna handcuff here
foreign
go ahead and put your hands in front of
you with your thumbs facing up please
what is my I mean what is my is this
gonna go like on the news
Mr Kinsey
once this gets reported then there will
be statements we'll have to release and
notes will have to send home to parents
and then news reporters will probably
show up
I will be as discreet as I can and in
terms of how I handle it we
please I've never been in trouble in my
life I understand it but again that's
not I'm not going to go pushing anything
out there
okay you did not
gotta respond and
let people know that we followed our
policy
[Music]
to get that done
all right yes
the classroom
those right there
you go
and is that all of it for the school
yes your school device here at school uh
yes
[Music]
he'll go with this officer here yes
Jennifer just follow me we'll go to my
car and
take you up to the jail thank you
yes ma'am
go this way
Seven Central 10 15 one female
foreign
[Music]
when you get there after all the
bookings done and everything
and then I can go home
um it just depends on on what the judge
says in the bond because you're gonna
have to see a judge and he'll set a bond
yeah I would hope that it's going to be
today but I I don't have any control
over there
you might we might be able to be all
right but like I said don't take my word
on that I can find somebody I know
somebody that can come
okay all right